- Rarement une absolution n'aura
autant semé la controverse.
Simon Houle a agressé
ment une femme et pris
des photos de ses parties
intimes, en 2019, à Trois-
Rivières. Alors que la poursuite
demandait 18 mois de prison,
la Cour du Québec lui fait
bénéficier d'une absolution
conditionnelle. Le juge veut
éviter qu'un casier judiciaire
l'empêche de voyager et gâche
sa carrière d'ingénieur.
MÉLANIE LEMAY, coordo, Québec
contre les agressions sexuelles
- On se sent trahis. On continue
de nous mettre dans un processus
qui est contradictoire parce que
tout est axé sur les droits
des agresseurs. La parole
des victimes, les conséquences
qu'elles ont vécues
sur leur vie, c'est pas
pris en considération.
- Le juge Matthieu Poliquin
souligne que l'agression
s'est déroulée somme toute
rapidement. Simon Houle areconne
victime dans le passé,
sans être accusé. Un signe de
transparence, selon le tribunal.
Le DPCP va porter la décision
en appel. Le cabinstre
de la Justice dit :
ISABELLE CHAREST, ministre resp.
de la Condition féminine, Québec
- Il faut faire en sorte que
les juges, que les procureurs,
en fait, tous ceux qui sontimpl,
aient une formation adéquate
pour que ces jugements-là
n'arrivent plus dans l'avenir.
VÉRONIQUE HIVON, porte-par porte
du PQ en matière de justice
- La lueur d'espoir que je vois
à travers cette décision
extrêmement choquante, c'est
cette volonté collective
de mettre en place des tribunaux
spécialisés. Et je pense que
si on avait besoin de preuves
supplémentaires qu'ils sont
nécessaires, bien, en voilà une,
tristement éloquente.
- Le jugement va à l'encontre
du mouvement MoiAussi et duRappr
l'accompagnement des victimes,
selon les oppositions.
ISABELLE MELANÇON, porte-parole
PLQ en matière de cond. féminine
s outrée. Je suis
fâchée, je suis déçue. C'est pas
avec un jugement comme celui-ci
qu'on va rebâtir la confiance,
justement envers le système
de justice, mais a
envers les victimes.
ALEXANDRE LEDUC, porte-parole
de QS en matière de justice
- Le signal que ça envoie à la
société, c'est com
un bon emploi, si on est
dans la bonne classe sociale,
on peut espèce de...
pas un passe-droit, mais
une considération particulière
qui nous permet d'éviter
carrémenn.
- L'employeur de S,
Canimex, a mis fin à son lien
d'emploi ce mardi, dans un
climat tendu. L'homme de 30 ans
demeure membre de l'Ordre
des ingénieurs du Québec.
Ici Genviève Garon,
Radio-Canada, Mon